hey everyone it's Jenna here it's a
turbo and it's only three months away to
a new year so I've decided to put
together a 90-day weight-loss challenge
to do you I know many of you is on a
weight-loss journey you all plan to go
on a weight-loss journey but you do not
know where to start
in regards to your workout plan all your
food plan so I've decided in the next
three months to put together a very easy
to follow workout and food plan just for
you so this workout plan is going to be
a 5-day workout plan consisting of three
days total body workout and two days
cardio interval plus core workouts for
maximum and best result in the next
three months I would recommend you to go
on the five-day workout plan together
with my food meal plan so the meal plan
will be between 1,200 to 1,500 calories
for women and between 1,600 to 2,000
calories for men whatever you do do not
consume less than 1200 calories for
women and do not consume less than 1600
calories for men because starving
yourself doesn't mean losing weight in
fact if you starve yourself your body
will hold on to the fat you are trying
to burn to know how much your body needs
and how much calories you should be
consuming in a day to lose weight please
click on this link and this video will
guide you step by step to show you how
much calories you will be meeting per
day if however you are really busy and
you do not have the time but you would
still like to join me on this 90 day
challenge I would recommend for you to
do two days of total body workout and
one day of cardio intervals plus call
therefore it will be a three day workout
plan it would still be as effective it
is very important for you to know that
losing weight is 80%
and 20% exercise therefore if you're not
willing to clean up your diet if you're
not willing to change your diet you are
basically wasting your time and effort
working out so the first step is to
clean your diet and to eat a balanced
diet that is key to losing weight every
fruit that goes into your mouth has
calories and you will affect your weight
and you will affect your waistline so if
you're really determined to lose weight
that needs to be sacrifices and changes
to be made on the fast food processed
food fried food chocolate bars
overloading your meals with cheese and
dairy products has got to stop you are
what you eat
so start cleaning up your diet and start
taking charge another tip to success is
you need to drop the mindset of quick
weight loss solution I have received
many emails and many comments asking me
how can I lose weight fast or how can I
drop 10 pounds in a week my answer to
you is do not expect to lose weight
without any hard work determination
quality time spent in the kitchen and
your time exercising because it just
isn't going to happen so the sooner you
drop the mindset of quick weight loss
solution and start putting your energy
and effort into it you will actually
start seeing real results with your own
effort and your own hard work the
recommended weight loss ratio is between
one to two pounds per week and it varies
individually the more you have to lose
for instance if you have 40 pounds to
lose
the quicker it you will lose the weight
because your body has more fat to burn
the less you have to lose for example if
you only have 5 pounds to lose the
slower you will lose it because your
body is toning up and burning fat at the
same time and it takes time to tone up
and burn fat because your body has less
to burn to lose one pound of fat you
will be looking at burning 3500 calories
on average so therefore if you want to
lose 1 pound of fat per week divide that
by seven days you will need to reduce
your calories by 500
day that can be done either by cutting
down 300 calories from your mill and
burning the extra 200 calories for
exercising or vice versa
so that is the recommended and
sustainable weight loss progress for
every 45 minutes of workout you do with
my video you will be looking at burning
between 300 to 400 calories and for
every intense 20 to 30 minutes of
workout you do with my video you will be
looking at burning up to 300 calories
again calories burn varies individually
it varies real age your sex your weight
your height your heart rate your
metabolic rate and many more other
factors therefore to check the exact
amount of calories burn is by wearing a
heart rate monitor it is a really good
way to check your workout progress how
much calories your butt and how much
calories you need to reduce from your
food intake so if you can do go out
there and get a heart rate monitor watch
all of my workout plans and my meal
plans will be available on my website
Joanna stone comm you can find a workout
plan by clicking on the fitness tab and
click on downloadable files this workout
plan is according to my workout videos
but I've also done another workout plan
for those of you who like to workout in
the gym at your own pace as for my meal
plan you can find that by clicking on my
food tab and click on downloadable files
all of these meals and recipes are also
available as videos under my meal plans
food and nutrition playlist which you
can click here do subscribe to my
website by adding your email address
here to receive notifications on my
latest videos male plants break up
plants recipes motivations and my
occasional blocks I would recommend for
you to print both the workout and the
food plan stick it on the fridge or
place it somewhere where you spend most
of your time and remind yourself why are
you doing the 90 day challenge
so on the day where you feel demotivated
or lazy just take the time to love
yourself and remind yourself that every
workout you do and every meal that you
prepare
kitchen is a step closer to where you
want to be you need to start loving
yourself now because if you don't you
will not love yourself after it is your
body so adoring at every step and
remember that you are stronger than you
think you are I would encourage you to
check your weight loss progress by
taking a picture of yourself at the
start of month one then take a picture
of yourself every month and to measure
yourself as well to track your witness
progress you can also click on this link
here and this video will teach you how
to track and measure your weight loss
progress more accurately and more
effectively so the first month is all
about getting started if you don't start
you will never achieve your goal so get
ready and get started on this
life-changing journey this is the
hardest month but stick by it and I
promise you by the end of month one you
will be looking forward to its month two
in month one we will be incorporating
changes and new habits to your lifestyle
which you might not be used to such as
the way you consume your food the
quantity you consume as well as starting
a workout routine if you're new to
working out remember to work out at your
own pace I know that it can be very
frustrating if you fail to complete a
workout or you feel so out of breath and
you just want to give up don't every
step that you do every moves that you do
every workout that you do will only make
you stronger day by day so keep
practicing the move keep doing the
workout and you will only get stronger
and the workout will only get easier so
don't give up start and keep doing it
when it comes to losing weight what we
want to be focusing on are the major
muscles in our body in order to burn fat
efficiently and the largest muscles in
our body are our legs exercises which
involves our legs will increase your
heart rate and burn fat the quickest
therefore this workout plan will be
focusing on our major muscles in order
to burn fat quick as for a meal plan
once you start this meal plan I would
say that there will be times where you
will be craving for your comfort food
as much as you can please stick to this
nail plan because losing weight is 80%
nutrition treat yourself once a week to
a reward meal where you can have your
comfort food but remember to consume it
in moderation if you're over indulge in
your comfort food even if it's just one
meal you will be wasting the entire
effort you have put in a week so
remember to indulge once a week one
reward meal in moderation and trust me
it will be worth it
so once I've completed month one your
body has pretty much adjusted to the
workout and you basically know the moves
instinctively month two is all about
progression we cannot stick to doing the
same workout and doing it the same
intensity and expect our body to change
therefore we need to progress by adding
more weights adding more reps and adding
more sets to our workout therefore you
are adding more intensity to your
workout as well by adding more intensity
to your workout what you're doing is to
reach under your muscles and turning
your body into a fat-burning machine
again hence month 2 is all about
progression and I will be uploading the
month 2 workout plan and month to meal
plan onto my website as well and for
month 3 it's all about reflecting and
fine-tuning so look back at your
progress and look at which areas do you
want to tune up more do you want to work
out more and reach areas which you like
to do small of course if you still have
a lot more body fat to lose continue
doing total body workouts focusing on
major muscles and aim to increase your
intensity month by month but if you're
happy with your weight and you would
like to turn it up or even to maintain
it then you can look at parts and every
single body that you would like to focus
more on so that's month 3 and same thing
the workout plans and the meal plans
will also be uploaded on to my website
and on New Year Day I want you to look
back on your entire three-month journey
congratulate yourself on where you were
and where you are at right now just take
the time
say well done by New Year 2014 it is my
wish for you to look at fitness as a
lifestyle and not a chore and all your
healthy meal plans are not sacrifices
anymore instead you would rather eat
healthy than eating those fried or
processed food because you expect your
body enough to treat it right and that
is my wish for you I will be guiding you
through this 90 day weight loss
challenge but I wouldn't want you to
rely on me instead I want you to make
this your own personal journey in
finding out how can I make healthy food
delicious how can I make my workout fun
and most importantly to be patient with
the result the best way to learn is to
educate yourself on food and exercises
by understanding what food is good for
you and what exercises you need to do
you will be able to sustain your weight
for life and that is what I want for you
not just to lose weight but to be able
to sustain your weight for life so start
now don't look back only look forward
because you can only move forward in
order to achieve your goal and remember
don't wait until you're achieve your
goal to be proud of yourself be proud of
yourself for every step you take towards
your goal all the best for new fitness
food and motivational videos please like
share and subscribe to my You Tube
channel and website do follow me on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter to stay
connected with me thanks guys
you